hi everyone hello hello
hi i have to tell you such a fan of your
movie i was watching it on my laptop i
had my little girl she was watching
another show and i kept going
at many different turns she kept going
mom are you okay and i'm like yes
this was such an adrenaline rush it was
a fantastic movie angelina
you did a lot of your own stunts was
that sort of what drew you
to a film like this uh not really doing
my own
i mean just to be in this world in this
kind of real world with
not um superheroes and fantasy but real
people
and and all of our characters uh
broken people emotional people but
pulling through and i think that's what
makes people
really tough is when they can do that um
but yeah we all got
we all got nice and dirty and roughed up
through this
yeah absolutely and did you know how to
chop wood and make a fire before this
film
i could make a fire but wood chopping
was not was not my thing it is now
i like it i love it um medina
can we just talk about you know a movie
with your character allison i mean wow
that scene where you kicked the bad
guy's butts
was amazing what was the most
challenging part of filming those really
intense scenes while trying to protect
you know your unborn child um
i think the most challenging part uh
just from a technical
uh standpoint was the stamina
of you know long days very physical days
and then
coming back ready to do it the next day
and do it safely
but um other than that like story wise
i feel like allison is just in this mama
bear protective mode and she's
you know she's not even thinking um that
was just all drive
yeah and finn when you cry i cry
you are a good crier my gosh
um how how tough is it for you to go to
that place
because you could just see it from the
inside out
well angelina pinches me on the neck
pretty hard
[Laughter]
uh no it's um it's not too hard i just
think of past experiences in my life and
draw from that yeah
well you were fantastic angelina when
you watch finn acting does it take you
back to you your first roles and
what advice if any did you give him on
set
you know he really didn't need my help
um but it certainly did take me back to
when i was
uh when you're young and you're
discovering what what you have inside
the tools you have and whether you can
access um these emotions when you need
to whether you can pull them up
when when you want to and and i could
see him
you know stretching and um
i i just could see a like a very
authentic
person and actor so i didn't have to
tell him anything but i was
excited to see it yeah for sure
well thank you so much everybody for
your time congratulations on the movie